every reporter and everyone in media
we've met
is on twitter and they're on it a lot
right they are the twitter twitter
is
the sports gambling
for
journalists yes
if you're on twitter you're gambling in
likes people you're gambling in
retweets on twitter in order to get good
at you have to just have takes it's just
takes and takes don't have room for
nuance because it's a short piece so
they're just like
what about that what about that and you
shouldn't do this you should do this
right it's that over and over and over
and it drives us to this like black or
white situation
and i just feel like we see it now in
the mainstream media that's out of
that's off of social media you see it in
the times you see in the post you see it
on tv right so much of mainstream media
coverage
is
like get a load of this person and let's
look down on them or shame them can you
believe that or cast them as immoral or
problematic right i think i just
summarized
what like 60 percent of media coverage
yeah
and
joe has given millions of americans
another outlet for that
and a million i mean others other
content creators have followed suit with
joe because they know there's this
massive hole in the market
[Music]
this week on forward the reaction to
last week's conversation on boys and men
online sports gambling the joe rogan
spotify controversy
fully robotic surgery this and [ __ ]
forward
[Music]
and we are back this week on forward
apparently people responded to that uh
last episode about men and boys boys and
men boys two men american
boys and men struggling and failing i
think that tweet by the way i'm going to
tell the story so check it out podcast
episode comes out on thursday and then
i'm like oh i should just tweet
something about this episode and so i
tweet
american men now comprise 40.5 percent
of college students which is by the way
a shocking statistic if you think about
it for a second
um
and uh you know this is something that's
going unreported under discussed and
then i sensed that that tweet was going
to get a lot of attention but right now
it's up to five million plus
impressions 52 000 likes like thousands
of
replies um mostly positive it seemed oh
yeah this is one of the best
okay just for context for everybody as
we dive into this because we have to
talk about it
we do a bunch of episodes where we have
a famous person on or someone with a big
following so
in matt like sagar and jetty or jack
dorsey or even marianne williamson
recently had more
especially on youtube like more
let's call it impressions or people
viewing it
but in terms of engagement and people
reaching out to us as human beings
overwhelmingly
our most positive episode in that sense
you know what i'm saying what you got i
mean the inbox flooded my comp comments
dms to me
everybody is apparently craving for
people to talk about this which is
shocking us because we knew no one was
talking about it well you know it was
interesting is like i was hitting this
topic very hard on the presidential and
my book the more normal people was
replete with facts and figures on the
decline of american men yeah three
chapters on it man yeah at least and uh
and so i'm of the type that and this is
maybe a failing of mine is that i think
okay like i've hit a message for a
particular period of time and then it's
like well everyone must have heard it
and then we go on to the next thing um
but then it turns out that
that this particular message i think you
could hit over and over again
and it would be new or controversial to
some
uh i'm glad that the feedback from our
audience has generally been positive but
i do think that it runs against the
grain of this dominant media culture
that frames men and boys as problematic
or
you know toxic
and
um
i think that that's not
productive you know if you have an
enormous segment
roughly half the population failing by
the numbers
it should be of concern to everyone
and one of the points that you're making
is that if you want women to thrive and
succeed and be well treated you would
want guys to not be falling apart yeah
we did get some twitter hate but it's
it's and we'll talk about this probably
later in the episode too when we talk
about
spotify and rogan and what's going on
there but um
is the folks that seem to hate on it
like the hate i got on twitter i tried
to look at all of it i actually don't
look at a lot but
the the things i saw that were negative
tended to be from people that clearly
didn't watch the episode or listen to
the episode you know and i think that's
a general thing where we
we've built this like hyper reactionary
like and then you get this comment like
oh of course two men say if you wanna
help women you gotta focus on men ha ha
and that's like
easy fodder to just kind of click like
or which if you like are in that lane
right you know back when i was a high
school debater uh there was this thing
called uh ad hominem which has just
attacked the speaker oh um and
that uh is considered a bad argument um
but now it's the most common argument uh
on twitter and other places which is
like
hey you know i'm going to state an
argument well [ __ ] you you're an [ __ ]
[ __ ] right it's like like the yes
that's like the main line of uh
argumentation now
and then that there is like this
obsession essentially with finding
whatever
uh moral flaws in someone's past so that
i can then attack anything they do as
like a well
you know you said this thing 10 years
ago like and and by the way this was
considered
not out of bounds in debate but as
something that you would
lose points for so tell me about ad
hominem so that's if you're you're
debating
whether or not
immigration how to solve for immigration
i'm not a political issue right and then
someone starts saying andrew last time
you were up there you were arguing for
something morally against this so screw
you like how does this no ad hominem's
just attacking the speaker okay so it
would be like you're personally going to
benefit from
the policy that you're advocating
or you're just a low character and low
integrity and we shouldn't be listening
to anything you say
um so that this is considered a weak
form of argumentation because it's like
well you're not actually addressing
whatever the heck i'm saying you're just
trying to undermine me but it's the most
common thing uh in american life today
yes is that and one of the things that i
had to start to accept and you accepted
earlier was that there is no separating
the message from the messenger in
american life today correct now i and i
believed that the message would
itself be
uh strong or powerful but it turns out
that people need a messenger to attach
it to and then it ends up inflecting the
message with all sorts of meaning
here's a good question do you think
republicans i'm just go back to maybe
what jonathan hate writes about in terms
of the well it's one reason why if you
have a book like woke racism could only
be written by black dude like john john
mcwhorter yep you know like anyone who
was your head yeah the messenger had to
be like hey guys i'm black
and a professor and by the way you know
like this stuff is
um not productive or cogent or coherent
even is there something
inherently
identifiable on the right or left that
or let's call it the right here that
helps republicans separate the message
from the messenger better than folks on
the left
that's a good question i hadn't really
thought so
one of the issues is that the
obsession with identity is stronger on
the left right
um one of the things i believe has
happened is that the the folks on the
right and conservatives are like well if
you just want to make everything about
race then maybe we should make
everything about race and by the way
we're white and there are a lot of us
and you know like let's just
like head that direction
which
uh is one of the traps by the way it may
be the trap uh i mean my my conversation
with
stephen marsh is about this topic as the
the main catalyst for
violence and civil strife in in the
united states and it's something that i
have always tried to
uh combat
which is that if you
segment us all into groups
then
um it becomes like a zero-sum
clash and being like well here's my
group
and this is what we're gonna take and
then you're gonna get this and you're
gonna get this and by the way one of the
reason why i always thought this was a
massive loser
is that there is one group
that is uh bigger richer more powerful
everything than everything else and so
you'd be like well if we just make this
a zero sum competition
then by the way like that group probably
wins yeah um and so
like maybe we should avoid that as like
your predominant
[Laughter]
argument or
criteria for
um policy
so i'm this i i've never heard of ad
hominem that's what it's called yeah ad
hominem before but it um it speaks to so
many things that have happened so trump
was probably the best example where
do you wrong there are plenty of things
wrong with
um
some of some of donald's arguments but a
lot of the attacks on him were character
focused or he's an actor i thought you
were going to say something else which
is anytime someone said anything
negative about trump he would be like
you're failing you're a loser oh sure
like i agree he actually did so one of
the things that he specialized in was
like don't believe anything these people
are saying because they're full of [ __ ]
yes and a lot of their hypocrisy yeah
and a lot of americans were eager to
hear that be like oh yeah because those
people are right but then they would
ignore i guess what i'm saying is
there's all these the left would hammer
trump on his character flaws but
the message actually resonated a lot of
folks where i mean build the wall
had some racial undertones but there was
a illegal immigration problem that we
weren't doing we weren't even really
addressing on the left or on the right
very well there was the drain the swamp
argument america is losing we need to
start winning again right these are
things that americans have felt
particularly in certain parts of the
country
and they ignored
the character flaws you know and they
got they like either
didn't believe they existed or a lot of
people held their nose right and voted
for the donald um i just didn't know if
that uh you almost had both sides of
that with with with with donald trump
right where he would attack people's
character and then everybody only attack
his character and ignore his message and
his message was strong
yeah that's true yeah
um
how'd we get off on this we
we were talking about
um we're talking about men boys to men
and the fact that we get attacked
because we're men talking about it yeah
and
i would say
um
there are some women talking about it
yes they've been the only folks talking
about it and then the other folks are
the women you think of when you think
about women talking about this i think
of liz planck
caitlyn flanagan yep katie herzog a bit
right i think i don't listen to her
enough
um
and um christine sommers there's a lot
of the idw types
intellectual dark web for those of you
who don't i guess that's this all used
to be a thing it strikes me as entirely
rational for women to look up and be
like hey if men
had their [ __ ] together things would
probably be better for everyone yeah
[Laughter]
like that doesn't seem like a radical
thought or statement
but it's not a lot
um and then there's a lot of folks that
talk about it
on the right and those are men
conservative usually christian men
talking about it on the right and i grew
up
knowing who those folks were so i mean
david ramsey is more about him finance
he's more of a he's like the finance
whiz but he incorporates a lot of like
manhood and responsibility and biblical
undertones or overtones in many ways he
talks um in his messaging uh you could
even argue a lot of conservative talk
radio folks in general like rush
limbaugh and and ben shapiro even at
times like they they kind of talk about
they're very pro family they're very pro
traditional role of man right um but i
agree it's it's not talked about enough
and it's not talked about at all from
the left which is where i think we're
getting
the
generally positive responses i don't
know if you agree with that you know
it's been like a far-right thing to talk
about well so the the the left is
primarily concerned with the power
differential yeah and so the the left's
framing of
just about any social issue will be
who's the marginalized weaker group
right who is the strong group and then
the mission has to be for the strong
group to
uh relinquish some of their power and
privilege to the the weaker group so in
this calculation it certainly seems like
men are the privileged group by just
about any number and so you think well
it can't be about the men it has to be
about uh women or girls or
you know non-binary or whoever the group
is and that overlooks the truth that it
turns out that a lot of men are failing
and struggling by the numbers for a
multitude of reasons a lot of boys are
struggling and failing uh and that there
is this
uh
truth too that if you look at any of the
uh catastrophic
social problems or criminal
uh behaviors or domestic terrorism or or
the rest of it it's almost always boys
or men
94 of school shooters are
boys
uh
now i'm sure a similar percentage of uh
domestic terrorists and the rest of it
so
if you have catastrophic male failure
it results in a lot of very very dark
tragic terrible things happening and it
and it bleeds together when i was
talking to stephen about this it's like
um you have mental illness you have
criminal behavior and then you have
political violence
and they're all kind of weaving together
um in this spectrum of male failure
right i think that's why i think that's
why we're passionate about that
passionate about this because
it's core and it does drive me up a wall
that for whatever reason left-leaning
media just seems to kind of miss this
stuff or
when they talk about men failing there's
zero empathy there's zero like hey some
something should be done about this it's
just like oh what the [ __ ] is wrong with
these guys right for collapsing
disintegrating etc even though if you
look at it it's like well we've gotten
rid of um the family unit we've gotten
rid of uh like apathy um to higher
education for a lot of them we've gotten
rid of a sense of purpose or community
or fulfillment we've gotten rid of a
secure middle-class livelihood we've
gotten rid of like a lot of stuff
and so then when you see the collapse
to me that should be a massive call to
action
but the empathy on the left is reserved
for people who are on what is perceived
to be the losing end of the power
differential
i think it's a massive miss for the
democrats and has been hurting them more
and more over time because you know who
cares about this issue the most
mothers suburban white mothers frankly
um now it's not top of their game like
our top their list at always but when
you talk to them about do they admit
this is a problem yes are they con any
mother of a boy understands this i think
innately
[Music]
okay listen up 90 of the coffee from the
grocery store is actually stale so you
heard that right the coffee you know and
think you love needs an upgrade so
instead of rebuying the same old same
old let trade coffee send you something
freshly roasted that you're literally
guaranteed to love so here's the deal
trade sells the freshest roasted and
ethically sourced beans from america's
best independent roasters they ship to
you for free as often as you like whole
or ground however you like it so whether
you're a coffee nerd or you just want a
better daily cup trades real coffee
experts taste test over 400 roasts and
use tech to match you with your ideal
coffee based on your preferences and
brewing methods so for me you just take
this quick quiz whether you like it dark
or light or you like it in a k-cup or
like a ground and then they ship it to
you based on what you've matched with
and it's awesome so you can take this
quick
quiz and then trade coffee guarantees
you will love your first bag or they'll
replace it for free
so they've been featured in the press by
wired and gq and have delivered over
five million bags of coffee like these
guys are legit there's no hassle you can
skip your shipments you can change your
frequency you cancel at any time
this stuff if you love coffee is a
better way to get awesome coffee and for
our listeners right now trade coffee is
offering a total of 20 off your first
three bags pretty great so that's if you
go to drinktrade.com
yang so to get started take their quiz
at drinktrade.com
yang and start your journey to the
perfect cup that's drinktrade.com
yang for 20 off your first three bags
check it out
[Music]
so we are going to make uh this
something of a recurring segment on the
podcast we're going to talk about an
issue that relates to men
maturation boys and so this time we're
going to do something that's going to be
considered fun-ish but i think is going
to be highly relevant to a lot of men
and that is betting on sports online
this is fitting because i lost
a good amount of money this weekend in
sports so this is top of mind for me and
zach because new york just legalized uh
online sports betting i will share my
own experience with this and so for a
little bit of background i would
commonly make jokes
about asians and gambling
um
when i was running for president i'd be
like well you know i like to gamble
because i'm asian
and that got some laughs and then people
were like oh is that a stereotype then
if you go to a casino there are a lot of
asians there and if you they're they're
buses from any asian community to
casinos like asians just like
uh it's like gambling right asians like
numbers chance
it's baked into the culture
is it
is it help me understand that this is
fun like why is there's an asian
stereotype that you have rich asians
love to gamble which asians do love
together
maybe just a rich people stereotype oh
but but there there is something baked
into asian culture around numerology
i'll give you an example and that
there's a western equivalent of this
if you have a stock ticker number that
has lucky numbers in it
there's a systematic bias for those
stocks to trade a little bit higher
interesting uh because we just really
like the number eight for example okay
uh you know like that number is very
lucky in
um in asian culture now the west has the
equivalent that if you have a stock
ticker that you can pronounce then that
actually gives your stock like uh you
know whatever it trades five percent
higher
um than if it's just you know an acronym
that no one could ever say so if you had
like the cheesecake factory stock was
cake
um crashes it i think it gets like a
five percent premium based on that makes
sense
on our company which would talk about
someday um
one company we ought to make sure we get
a ticker that
that sounds cool you sail out yeah
apparently it's worth a five percent
premium but asian culture having a bunch
of eats in your stock ticker um is worth
like uh you know five to eight percent
premium okay so asians like numbers
asians like chance yep match made in
heaven and so there's a cultural
proclivity towards
uh games of chance and
uh and gambling and i just looked this
up i was looking this up
and i haven't verified this but i think
we can verify this piece is that the
majority of gamblers
majority of people who bet are men
um by a lot sports betting
it's somewhere like half of sports fans
are women but
almost three-quarters i'm giving her a
take and we can find maybe the exact
numbers about three-quarters of of
people who gamble our men
um and then problem gamblers about twice
as many men
um are addicted as as women so if you
live in new york you've been inundated
with promos for sports books oh my gosh
it's fanduel draftkings caesar caesars
so each of them so which offers did you
take and how much free money did they
give you i did caesars they gave me 500
free bucks
and i did fan dual
which was kind of fake they gave you a
thousand dollars free
but you had to
it was only it would match your bet and
then if you want it you could only use
it in their app it wasn't actually
dollars it was it was a credit because i
did the same thing i joined fanduel and
got the thousand dollar right uh back
but i was like i don't really get it but
caesar's actually like matched a couple
of your first bets and you could
actually cash out on it i'm going to
share i'm going to share um what i did
with my fanduel thousand dollar credit
okay oh my gosh
okay so i i bet on the ufc heavyweight
title fight uh francis angano against
people love that yeah um so i
you know bet because i said well they're
guaranteeing a loss of a thousand so i'm
going to bet a thousand on this fight
um and i gotta say that i was so nervous
because because my god was losing
um and then uh angano pulled it out uh
by wrestling
and so i won a thousand and obviously
felt pretty good because it's like you
know it's a good feeling
so
uh so you win a thousand i'm now
when i was running for president i said
look we should legalize
um online poker and gambling and and i
believed that because
there was a way to do it anyway there
were illicit ways
like you'd rather it be regulated and
prohibition doesn't really work there's
a few things that it works on and that's
we could maybe have a whole episode on
that but yeah yeah but now that i'm
experiencing it oh my gosh is this stuff
addictive
you've don't you forget it's real money
yeah so then the next thing i bet on
was now you're hot was there yeah so now
i'd like you know three bucks
um so then i i bet on a parlay an nba
game
where the best it was
it was a bunch of things happening in a
knicks bucks game a parlay for those who
don't gamble because i'm learning a lot
of this is when you bet on lots of
things to happen and they all have to
hit so i can bet on the bills win and
i've been on five other teams to win two
or i can do like mid game stuff where
it's like so and so would have so many
points or so many touchdowns so many
yards and they all have to hit or you
you know four or five bets
hit and one misses you lose everything
so then i i watched the nba game the
knicks bucks game and any time
someone scored a bucket got a rebound
that was involved in my parlay i'd be
like yeah and then i'd be like pass it
to my guy so he can yes it changes
it changed the way i watched it it was
more entertaining yes um it made me a
shittier dad for two hours because i was
just like had the game on it and you
know my sons were a little bit like why
the hell you care so much about what's
going on and by the way i i really
shouldn't have cared because i bet
whatever
like 50 bucks or or whatnot so the
return on high right
it was so this particular thing was five
to one okay and the crazy thing is i won
you one you were on a heater man this
was this weekend uh it was like last
week whenever the ship was going down
great um so so now that i've had this
direct experience with it i have to say
that i understand how people can get
addicted it changes your relationship
with sports like you had i had this
stupid stupid sense that i was being
productive watching this game because
you can change your bets in the middle
so you feel like you're earning you're
doing it you're like you're just like
productive wow and the way a lot of guys
are programmed is that if you can make
some money
then it feels smart feels like
achievement feels practical feels like
work wow i mean uh yeah you're right
yeah so
um so uh now i know myself well enough
to know that i'm gonna go through this
arc and then get tired of it and then
think like this is a bad use of my time
um and move on yeah but i can easily see
how people fall down this rabbit hole
and get addicted
lose lots of money
uh and these sites it is wild where they
must have done the math where they give
you a thousand free gambling bucks
and they know that they're going to get
it back oh they know
the house always wins that's a thing
about gambling right those businesses
don't exist they make a ton of money and
they don't they wouldn't exist if they
weren't winning all the time i would say
so you and i do not have fundamentally
addictive personalities but i know we
all both know
every guy has friends
who are usually like i'm a guy i used to
do these snooze little tobacco pouches
as like uh
on the campaign too when i was getting
through i was like a little buzz i was
like it's like they're pansy they're
like tiny like these are not strong
tobacco um and they are addictive like i
felt being addicted i felt craving them
um
but one day i was like i can't do this
anymore i just quit and up and quit it
was like rough for two days and that's
that and most folks i know
my brother included like he loves them
he can't stop using them right um
and
sports betting those types of things
like i i lost some money i was like
if i had to keep betting 20 bucks a game
like there's a lot of games like
it's not going to work out well for me
um but but we wanted to talk about this
because
men in particular struggle with this and
we're attracted to this
do you think
it used to be illegal
because of what we're talking about i
think where people were concerned about
men blowing their money and now we're
like i think men are smart enough
um i don't think whatever it doesn't get
any smarter and you have to look at the
numbers one of the things that happens
anytime you interact with gambling is
there's always an ad like got a gambling
problem yes they call this number the
laws right yeah yeah the the laws
so despite my affection for gambling
personally like i know enough about it
to know that it's generally a net
negative for
the community
it's a bit of a black hole
it tends to absorb economic vitality so
what happens if you open a casino is you
say look i'm going to create you know
300 500 jobs
and that's the argument um but what
most don't realize is that
generally speaking the people in the
surrounding area
uh spend money at the casino and then
the
bulk of the money
goes to the owners and the owners tend
not to live where the casino is
and so the casino
is generally a bit of a net negative
um on the surrounding
economic side but and they're also live
destroyed because they're dudes who uh
can't handle it and like lose all their
savings et cetera and if you go to a
casino and you looked around um you
would probably find at least a few
people where you're like you know i
don't think they should be gambling as
much as they're gambling the sad
depressed gambler everybody knows that
guys yeah like when you go
you see that stuff now so what's
when i was running for mayor of new york
city i advocated for a casino in new
york despite everything i just said
because in new york's case there's a ton
of tourists who come in and it would be
actually added we'd get money from
people outside the city yeah yeah um
but but typically if you had a
casino it's not going to be that much of
a boon
um to the surrounding area one of the
reasons why again i've gotten on board
with a a general legalization of this
stuff is that when i was traveling the
country over the last number of years i
was stunned at how many casinos there
were like america has essentially
legalized gambling where um i'll give
you some examples
downtown cleveland casino downtown new
orleans casino
uh detroit that's right three casinos
now philadelphia proper no but then if
you leave town like
western pa casinos you drive around
california uh you'll pass casino so like
over time i started to realize like wait
a minute we've really
essentially made this legal
um in a ton of vicinities around the
country
and so if you're already at that point
then
you should try and do it intelligently
and do it in a way that's regulated and
the rest of it
now that i've
directly interacted with online sports
betting because i wasn't able to before
because it wasn't legal i i will confess
too occasionally i would still bet on
sporting events you find a bookie or
whatever right yeah yeah like i call it
i have a guy so what happened was it was
legal in jersey yeah i had a jersey guy
so yeah so if you have a jersey friend
they can just do it 100 legal and just
be like hey you know can you place a bet
for me and then you settle up right but
wow is this going to
uh consume a ton of
time energy resources for
tons of guys and on one side it is fun
and social because you put a bet on
something like i had a friend who
had like a couple thousand dollars in
the game yesterday and so the niners
rams game right and so then when i was
watching the game like i was betting
hard for him like i was like please let
him win just because yeah we're gonna go
because you know your friend has a
couple thousand bucks on it there's just
gonna be so much energy
and some people are gonna lose
more than they should some people are
going to end up with
it's going to ruin lives yeah you can
sense that
we should maybe see if we can get an
expert on this or talk to some folks
we're looking to have on but um
do you think this is coming from a guy
who by the way was like essentially for
it
yeah yeah um
well being against it makes it um
causes other problems right which is
it's not about the morals or whether or
not it's good for
humans it's about the policies and
whether that's yeah that implementation
is realistic and practical
so look very rich people gambling
probably a good thing right because that
let them blow their money and
someone
ideally you could tax it right and throw
back in the community in the economy
to me if you have men
who are jobless
or on disability
or don't feel like they have a good
economic path forward
and so
three to one five to one 20 to one odds
and some of these bets they're making on
their paycheck for example
seems pretty good in some ways it's like
a lot of folks many ways why they play
the lottery
because
i know the odds are terrible but it
feels like
frankly hope or upside do you think that
has anything to do with it i'm sure it
does that has a lot to do with it for
sure i think i think guys want
to feel like there is some chance of
making it big relatively speaking and
just introducing that possibility if you
were to tell
a guy hey like you're going to be within
these bounds
and uh there's not going to be any
possibility that you break through like
this relatively low ceiling that would
be a huge bummer to most any guy right
it's like you you like to think
that maybe
i can hit it big
um whether that's in your career whether
that's
by getting on a hot streak when you go
to a casino
yeah yeah like they're like there's a
little bit of a craving for
um volatility and upside
i agree gambling sports gives you some
of that like feeling a part of something
um but this
gambling does too but it has the the
dark consequences of being
for many their food money or their their
bills money and um so i was watching nba
games on tnt
uh and it was sponsored by fanduel yeah
oh yeah and then it has mainstream now
and they had the odds up there i think
there was a parlay
on tnt being like hey you can do a
parlay right now espn has shows
dedicated to the prop bets to the bets
yeah um
it's real it's mainstream and it's
let's get the policy piece of this if
you're
a government
you know it's bad for people but it's
worse if you try and regulate it many
ways right where we got all this dark
money going through we're not taxing it
you've got men it would move it to the
cayman islands more or less and you'd
have like some weird outfits like how
would you
so as a government is the key to like
let these types of things be legal
because regulating them becomes a
nightmare but also beef up your social
safety net and your resources for men
like what's the solution here
if it is legal i i would like there to
be some people are going to dislike this
but like i think if you had
uh enough data and a good ai algorithm
you could actually see who the hell is
going to spiral and when they're
spiraling uh
like based upon like gambling patterns
and the rest of it
um so saying like hey do you have a
gambling problem it's like if i have a
gambling problem i'm probably going to
lose my shirt before i call somebody
all these days and weeks and months and
maybe years leading up to that gambling
problem you've been ignoring that though
hey got a gambling problem you're used
to fast forwarding that ad right so
there'd be at least a couple of inputs
you could have
um one would be let's say i start on
fanduel which i did
um
that there could be like uh hey like how
much money do you want to lose or can
you afford to lose uh you know before
the fact
um and then you know i give a range be
like look i don't want to lose more than
whatever x thousand yeah x thousand
dollars
um and then uh and then if i start
losing more next thousand dollars and
fanduel will be like hey uh it's time to
yeah it's a little bit like like a
bartender yeah trying to you know like
stop serving your drinks that they know
you're like drinking out of control um
so one would be a self-stated like
comfort level and then the other would
be like i can pretty much tell from your
gambling behavior
whether you're losing your [ __ ]
um
you bet x thousand dollars on like weber
state versus yeah like you're kind of
going you're nowhere near off the rails
here
um i mean the tough thing is that if
fanduel were to cut you off you just hop
to somewhere else caesars and the rest
of it well i wonder um
and look i i agree with the
free country you spend your money how
you want like that's you know what
people theoretically should be able to
do but i do think
we regulate
investment markets based on this right
you can't invest and part of them are a
little problematic especially as crypto
is democratizing some of this and robin
hood as we've talked about this pod
before but there's some like hey if you
are not worth x amount of dollars you
can't invest in that um right you are
required to read this disclosure you're
required to go through a broker dealer
you're you know it's ver and like i
don't love all of these rules but they
do
prevent
shady money or immature money or
people that should not be doing things
they prevent them from doing them they
do work in that way generally a lot of
the regulations in our securities
markets are on the companies themselves
in the nature of the securities
um what do you what how do what do you
mean by that like in order to be listed
you have to jump through like a
gajillion correct yep so that's another
thing too you know
um
like if you're betting on stocks like
it's not a penny stock generally
speaking right if it's listed on the new
york stock exchange right you know that
but also if you wanted to do
hedge funds or options or various
alternative investments you have to have
250 000 in net worth or a minimum
usually or accredited investors better
investor regulations things like that um
and we'll change subjects a bit but this
is
what i want to talk about when we do
this section i think you do too is that
there's a masculine urge to participate
in this there's a mat there's a
innate biological human
need for men to get involved in this
type of stuff some of them we can
explain some of them we almost can't
but if men don't understand
yeah how to navigate this you end up in
with problems so what would your
recommendation be to folks navigating
this new world of like
uh this is like the
golden age of sports gambling right just
i will share with you my personal
approach yeah and then we'll leave it at
that okay is uh i i've said look i'm
going to put
a certain amount of money out of this
and in my case it's really not much
money i think it's like you know two
thousand dollars
and then i'm gonna gamble it and do
whatever the hell i want but i'm not
going to put more money on this app
for
you know x period of time
and so set a rule like that for yourself
and then if you see yourself breaking
that rule then really give yourself like
like a very very long look in the mirror
yeah um you know and and it could be
even go to someone close to you and say
hey look
like fyi i'm you know it's like uh you
know seem obsessed about this thing like
let me know like in my case i could go
to evelyn and be like hey if i like like
go down this board scaling rabbit hole
like um like let me know that uh hey i
wanted i wanted you to tell me if i was
going overboard
um so so but you know in my case like i
i'm confident that uh like i'm not going
to put any more money on the app then
like i've already kind of set in my head
um so just set a rule for yourself and
then
take it very very seriously right if you
find yourself breaking that rule i agree
with that what how i did it was um i
have two i did two of the apps i have
caesars and fanduel um and i said i'm
going to put
200 in each
and i consider it gone that's how i
approach vegas too when i go if i ever
go to vegas i'm going to spend time i
have a you know it's a thousand bucks
i've saved up and it's gone you know if
i walk out of there with
two thousand dollars great but i'm
assuming i'm gonna walk out with zero
and it's your entertainment dollars
that's how i like gambling is fun right
i think that's okay to admit that and so
um well it's not fun it's like drinking
it's like any vice right like
in moderation awesome
too much
lose your [ __ ] dude um and that's part
of i think we're talking about being a
man like you could do it but you won't
right that's a big part like yeah you
could spend all your money on that and
risk it all but you won't because
you're the right kind man you want to be
or whatever it is so um
that's our gambling piece let's even get
a gambling expert on here too if there's
such a thing i'm sure there are right
um if anyone wants a comment off in the
youtube or uh twitter give us give us
some folks we'll reach out um
but that's our weekly segment on this i
want to call it bros to men unless you
have a better name
i mean there's not plenty of better
names yeah i would uh we'll work on the
title
[Music]
man
the media mainstream media loves talking
about joe rogan and we need to talk
about what's been going on yeah joe
rogan for whatever reason has become the
boogeyman to mainstream media
and like the punching bag they just love
to
they just love putting his name in the
headline that's for sure
um
so you want to summarize what's happened
i think most people have its general
idea the main new events been that a
number of musicians primarily neil young
have come out and said hey spotify i'm
going to yank my music right from
your service if you don't yank joe rogan
joe rogan and joe had two i wrote all
these names down so joe had two
doctors on his podcast that are the main
ones they're concerned about dr peter
mccalla who was
the vice chief of internal medicine at
baylor university which is a big deal
and a professor at texas a m
and he's according to joe and a few
other sources he's the most published
cardiologist in his field
um
and then robert malone
who was had a number of patents that
helped create
the mrna vaccines we use now these folks
are accomplished but have been known to
say things that are
against the grain and flagged as
misinformation
when it comes to the copid vaccination
so
neil young
joni mitchell
are like i'm pulling my music off so i
have questions for you on this the press
is going nuts uh
nuts it's covered at every outlet all
the time la times is like there's
certain outlets are like here are new
places to stream your music because you
hate joe rogan
um
and i will give credit for dive in joe
has also had left-leaning doctors on his
podcast and i think a lot of people
don't
or complaining maybe don't ever listen
to joe rogan but he's had sanjay gupta
on he has had michael osterholm um who's
on biden's coveted advisory board like
he has had
other folks on the other side of this
issue to be fair um
so
there's a bunch of questions here andrew
um
let's start with the first one we kind
of just landed on why are they so
obsessed with joe is it because they're
dying i think it's because joe is the
most prominent yeah now i mean his
audience dwarfs mainstream medias by
most measures and so i think there's
like a
kind of rivalry
aspect to it that joe's success in a way
calls into question
uh the
reason for being for certain
mainstream media outlets and he dwarfs
them right like jim acosta the new
primetime cnn show gets
a couple hundred 200 to 400 000 viewers
a night joe rogan we're talking about
11 million just on audio um and more on
youtube
um there's two pieces of this i want to
talk about the misinformation which i
think is
getting warped and then i think will be
fun is also talk about the business
piece of this too and like how
capitalism is fueling yeah the
misinformation piece let's start there
um so joe is getting
hammered for and that's why they're
pulling out that you're giving out
misinformation you're killing people is
what they're saying directly um
but misinformation seems to be a moving
target
um
depending where we are in the sense that
if you had said this was what joe said
in his response he's like if you had
said
vaccinated people can't get covered or
sorry if you um if you are vaccinated
you can still spread covid
or if you said cloth masks don't work
those are two facts we have the opposite
information on now but if you had said
that at some point in time over the past
two years you have been kicked off many
social media platforms
so what are your thoughts on how we're
defining misinformation and i don't mean
we like the media but like the actual
regulation like thought on
um
how this is used how it's defined
especially during a time of crisis uh
it's tough because joe rogan
uh
is not the mainstream media and like he
doesn't have some editorial
board type process he's just a guy who's
had conversations with people that he
wanted to talk to and then just became
wildly popular to a point now where his
audience is so huge that you can look at
it and say okay whatever goes out on
this platform actually is going to be
important and move the needle and so if
he
popularizes certain beliefs that are
incorrect
um that there could be you know some
negative negative consequences
um he launched
our campaign your presidential campaign
essentially yes oh very much so yeah uh
so
for joe
he has on doctors of different points of
view and then he has conversations with
them right um
like i i personally
think that spotify's current approach
which is like we're just gonna put an
advisory in front of
uh conversations that cover this topic
um seems like the right balance uh like
i think it would be
um it would be a real sea change for joe
to be like enforcing particular
um messages or let's say someone said
something that he thought was wrong and
if you're a mainstream journalist and
that happens then you kind of jump in
and like beat the person down yeah and
that's and to be fair they have an
editor in their ear or a producer in
their ear being like that's wrong we
just fact checked hammered him um yeah
it's not just that it's just a one man
show when you do that right yeah uh and
so i think that joe's not going to to
do that you know one because he doesn't
have someone in his ear
number two is that it's not really his
style to bring someone onto a podcast
and then try and
mold the message in a particular way
so i think that
you know like it that there's a tension
um
it does
call into question what is a
misinformation because the cdc's
guidance on the stuff has been a moving
target
right uh and and
i was struck by the fact that there are
various artists
that are saying essentially hey kick
someone else off
um or
or else like like that that struck me as
frankly not a great precedent
um where
if you disagree with something someone
else is saying on a platform right and
then
say
well you know on to their credit it's
like do they themselves take a hit of
some kind if they remove themselves from
spotify yes right um so that so that's
good
um you know they're they're making a
determination right they're making their
own the determination but that there is
like uh
i'm glad that the ceo of spotify hasn't
been like oh yeah let me like take joe
down and and do this because there is
this really nasty
trend around trying to de-platform
where it's like oh this person
and and like you said a lot of the
people that are trying to de-platform
your organ have never spent any time
actually listening to joe rogan the
premise of the show is like two people
having a long conversation right and you
get to flush all your ideas out and joe
gets to push back and we get to decide
what's true or not and many of it is the
pursuit of truth right a lot of it is
which is how you get there it's disgust
discussing and debating and arguing um
and
i mean trying to censor that kind of
defeats the whole purpose right um do
you think capitalism fuels this because
to me looking at this like you're
spotify like never are you going to you
invested 100 million plus
into joe and his audience is much much
bigger than whoever else he's bigger
than i mean unless it's like
i don't know is it
there's like probably 10 20 artists that
are bigger than joe rogan and joe
probably has better engagement number
because they're listening for longer and
more frequently well this is the weird
thing too is that i'm
90 confident
that joe's audience is smaller because
he's on spotify yes for sure it's
definitely dropped
and so it's still big right no well well
this is my point is that if you succeed
in d platforming him from spotify
it actually will likely grow his
audience yes and exposure because you
don't need to necessarily be a spotify
subscriber to listen to him
um so that part struck me as kind of
like odd
well that's the irony the whole thing
this whole thing is giving more pr to
joe and he probably has more listeners
from this keep going
which is
in your zeal to de-platform someone
um like what are you trying to
accomplish
uh if it's look i think this person's
point of view should never see the light
of day this will not accomplish that
right um it's going to make his stuff
more
accessible rather than less accessible
the only
rationale i can think of is that you
think that he's getting institutional
legitimacy from being on spotify that he
would not if he was just on youtube for
example right i'm struggling a little
bit with that argument because it's not
like spotify is like the arbiter of
of
you know whether something is
you know popular or acceptable
so so it's just a weird one where on
that one it's like look if if you
um if you want this point of view to be
suppressed this isn't the way to achieve
it i don't think
it's um let me ask you this like it
seems like
so much the world is going in this black
or white situation like nuances yeah and
that's what troubles me about it uh on
the side of it's like hey i disagree
with that person so we should quote
unquote kick them off because they're
evil and they're wrong and they're bad
yeah
and
the reality is most people have some bad
and
hopefully more good and right like like
people are coming well and here's like
the the kind of weird thing it's like so
first let me say do i believe in the
vaccines yes do i think that people
should get uh get boosted yes but if you
think about what the quote unquote
establishment is saying um it's very
much what uh i just said you know like
to the nth degree there are some
excesses in my opinion like should kids
be wearing masks in school
the the data is very fuzzy
on that rationale like i i'm leaning no
because
like one of the frustrations i think is
like
they they act like kids wearing masks
has no negative impact
on the kids or they're learning and by
the way it almost certainly does yeah so
you know like how much do you want to
weigh that what is the health benefit
yeah like there's this so to the extent
that there is like um
an establishment point of view
it's
covid countermeasures to the extreme
um and then the anti-establishment point
of view would be like wait a minute does
that make sense wait a minute like are
there legitimate reasons to like be
doubting some of this this guidance um
and then that's the stuff that's getting
shouted down
and what's interesting to me is that
traditionally artists have been like
this anti-establishment crew
you know and and but in in this case you
could make an argument that anyone who's
questioning this stuff is like the
anti-establishment yeah well it's tough
to watch because
the mainstream media is so quick to
point out the flaws of the the joe
rogans of the world or the the
alternative medias but the reality is
they only exist because mainstream media
is dropping the ball they've eliminated
nuance
[Music]
let me ask you this
i think maybe this answer is really
obvious but i don't think i've ever
asked you
every reporter and everyone in media
we've met
is on twitter and they're on it a lot
right they are the twitter super twitter
is
the sports gambling
for
journalists yes
[Laughter]
if you're on twitter you're gambling in
likes people you're gambling in
retweets on twitter in order to get good
at you have to just have takes it's just
takes and takes don't have room for
nuance because it's a short piece so
they're just like
what about that what about that and you
shouldn't do this you should do this
right it's that over and over and over
and it drives us to this like black or
white situation
and i just feel like we see it now in
the mainstream media that's out of
that's off of social media you see it in
the times you see in the post you see it
on tv right so much of mainstream media
coverage
is
like get a load of this person and let's
look down on them or shame them can you
believe that or cast them as immoral or
problematic right i think i just
summarized what like sixty percent of
media coverage after yeah
and
joe has given millions of americans
another outlet for that
and
a million i mean others other content
creators have followed suit with joe
because they know there's this massive
hole in the market but my ques my
question is like capitalism
seems to be pro misinformation it's pro
any information
as long as someone's willing to click it
and i'm curious your thoughts on well
capitalism is pro the splintering
of the american consciousness and the
splintering of the media landscape
that's where
capitalism is going to lead us
especially in this era because so if you
rewind
30 years or what not and let's say i had
some bad [ __ ] ideas um like how would i
get attention to them quite difficult
yeah you know like i i could like write
a letter to the editor that they would
ignore
i could
um
you know like put up some
bulletin board uh
leaflets i could stand in the town
square with a sandwich board uh you know
it's like it
it's tricky for me to gather together an
audience for my
insanity
um now
i don't need much you know i just need a
camera and a bit of a personality and
then i can put something out and so
whatever point of view you put out there
there's going to be a marked demand for
an alternative to it because people
especially in an era by the way of
collapsing institutional trust where
it's like what are they telling me [ __ ]
that [ __ ] like that can't be right like
oh this person this person's here to
tell me why they're full of [ __ ] right
um so there's there's going to be this
massive demand for
uh like a different unvarnished point of
view unfortunately a lot of that stuff
is going to be in opposition to the
stuff um that that came before which is
which is something that's interesting
about like a dynamic that even you and i
share
so
like i just listed a bunch of facts
about the decline of american men right
um and that somehow gets cast as
ideological even though all that stuff
it's just numbers this is numbers you
look it up and really this and that but
one of the reasons why it
became uh really popular and interesting
is because people sense that it's in
opposition to the mainstream media
narrative which is not talking about the
collapse of american men because that's
off of their
chosen direction like that their chosen
direction
is spotlight uh various marginalized
groups are men are the problem because
they are in positions of power and
therefore you must yeah there's a zero
sum it's like oh in order for other
people to succeed other people have to
fail so so one of the reasons why it
took off is because it's in opposition
to the conventional
media right narrative correct so that if
you have this conventional narrative and
then you're going to have this massive
demand for what's left unsaid
and then there's going to be a whole set
of people that fill it attract an
audience this may be why people are so
eager to
try to prevent any of this crew from
getting a degree of institutional
credibility because they can look at it
and say well sure your audience may be
an or mr rogan but you don't have the
legitimacy of this msnbc contributor
because they're on cable tv and we would
never let you on right
what i don't understand is these
institutions are dying right by the
numbers right um cnn msnbc even fox
but they're still around and they're
still driving our culture is capitalism
going to crush them or are they so kind
of
buoyed by
other forms of american life to keep
them in the game you know like this joe
rogan becomes cnn like what uh i was
thinking about why these cable news
channels have such power and currency
yeah and a lot of it is that they're
they're very very lucrative they're very
very profitable uh to the two to
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
so if you get knighted by one of them uh
they pay you
uh and
there are so many media figures who are
looking at it being like wait a minute
like if i end up on air with one of
these networks they'll give me six
figures for a part-time job and that's
one of the sweetest gigs
uh so so all of the various folks in
this universe want to be knighted
by uh the the cable networks there's
also a lot of vanity and i will say the
production values are very very high
where uh you know they make they make me
look good to make anyone look good where
like you go on there and they like oh
yeah they like make you up and put you
on the studio and the rest of it like
they build up the republican candidates
for fox news is very intentional about
you know you get more air time in there
your polls start rising you can contend
for presidency or whatever it is and
their audience is the sweet spot of
primary electorate voters
because they're in their 50s and 60s and
if you look at who's voting in these
primaries it's those folks no they're
older than that but yeah the average
viewer of cnn is 59 the average fox
viewer is 65. part of it too is that the
production values are higher so that if
you even see an online clip
of them
like it just seems
yeah it just seems more legit the people
have makeup on the studios are nice uh
it's one reason why crystal and sagar
they talked to me about their set on the
hill which is that if you had a video
clip of that and it got sent to
someone's parents they would look at it
and think it was legitimate because it
looked like it might have been on on
camera correct and that was a thing when
we were running for president 2020
legitimization was a big thing right
like getting and that they control that
for sure um and it's because there's a
lot of money and influence and
frankly production value behind it but
anyway i feel
like we're just at the beginning of like
i i don't see it end in sight for more
more and more um
joe rogan polarization if you will and
spotify might be the vehicles my
prediction is
something else gonna happen on joe's
podcast that when it's sound clipped and
when it's a short clip it's going to be
super objectionable and it'll be a big
artist that's like i'm pulling off
spotify
and maybe spotify has a decision to make
maybe it's a no-brainer but it then
politicizes i'm we're i'm worried about
politicizing our artists and our music
you know
over something that i don't think is
that controversial which is long
conversations with pretty much anybody
he'll take anybody who's interesting i
don't know if you think that's ever
going to happen or if it's just going to
be noise
i'm not sure that there's going to be an
issue that's quite as
freighted and fraught as kovid
you know like i have a hard time
imagining what else you could do that
would
be
as objectionable as your world oh just
wait man they'll be a new big boogie man
in a couple of years i'm sure yeah maybe
yeah i don't know i mean like it's less
yeah if we're more and more like
irrational then it will take less to do
it but well that that yeah that will
happen that's probably true
oy vey man um good for spotify for
pulling out um for holding strong i
guess and i think
joe handled it well i thought his like
he's like i had no hard feelings to neil
young or joni mitchell like i'm still a
fan he told a story in his release about
how he like went to a neil young concert
as a kid um
so
buckle up i guess if we're cool enough
that'll happen to us you know what i'm
saying
well didn't we just talk about how
american boys and men are failing and
that's a problem we get cancelled
we'll get cancelled make more news i
guess
[Music]
you want to close with this robot yes so
the last thing is that there was a fully
robotic laparoscopic surgery uh that had
better results than if done by a human
surgeon now it was on animals on pigs
yeah
because they didn't want to test this
stuff out on humans but the results were
very very positive and
i this is a big deal and this is
something i've been waiting for in a
particular way
now
uh i have friends who are surgeons
and they are very very afraid of doing
anything that might hurt their fingers
and hands so they don't ski they don't
play basketball they don't do things
because that their livelihood is in
having these fine motor movements
one of them you know that i went to
college with used to play video games
and be like i'm training because he's
like
working on his motor skills
so you have these highly educated humans
uh who are then these fine-tuned manual
technicians for hundreds of thousands in
some cases millions of dollars a year
their careers actually end on the
earlier side because after you get to a
certain age you can't do this anymore
yeah you know you you don't want a 60
year old surgeon freaking operating on
you you know it's your eyes too it's
coordination it's your balance it's a
whole bunch of things right yeah so you
can imagine i was a little bit like
athletes so they have longer careers
than that obviously but you know like
but by the time they're in their 50s
like that they're just talking uh to
others about how to do it um you know
and then showing them some things but
you know you don't want them doing it
now so imagine very very finely tuned
motor work sometimes you would
would involve movements that might even
be almost imperceptible
to the human eye this stuff is tailor
made for automation yes you know and and
so the fact that now they're getting to
a point where you could theoretically
replace human surgeons on these uh on
these
operations
is a potential game changer and so it
should be something that humanity
welcomes right like anyone who thinks
like oh humans should be doing surgery
you've got to be out of your [ __ ]
mind because when it comes down to it
this is just like some very very fine
motorcycle like uh imagine if if you had
uh you know an analogous
task that needed to be done
let's say it was like you know putting
like you know like tiny components um
into an airplane
like
who would you rather do that like a
robot that's designed for it i'm
guessing yes yeah or would you want to
have like hundreds of different humans
[Laughter]
that you then roll out you know and you
know not and surgeons are human beings
at the end of the day like can they have
bad days sure of course you know now you
hope that they you know like
they don't they don't and you hope that
they don't decide not to conduct surgery
that day right um but does that happen
for sure yeah
so like i i've been thinking about this
for a while that there is for a while
now there's been
robot assisted surgery
where you could have a human surgeon
manipulating like a robot hand
but this time the human wasn't involved
it's just robots doing their thing right
this one to me because we talk about
automation a lot and you know we also
about we talk about the management of
the automation crisis and the the
the chaos that will ensue after
something whether it's which goes back
to boys and men right now um
this one i feel will be
managed better than most i think
because you have all these hospitals
with their boards and all the
regulations around new medicines and new
procedures right so i imagine you and
you've kind of talked about this before
like you can't do the robot surgery
without a major surgeon or accredited
surgeon in the room like overseeing it
right but and i i my hope is that it you
don't end up with a whole bunch of
unemployed surgeons although you know
another reason why this is a pure good
there's a massive shortage of surgeons
is it really yeah if you if you go
around like to a lot of parts of the
country it's a freaking uh healthcare
desert oh so you'd have to go a long way
to like find an appropriate surgeon you
go to other parts of the world oh yeah
but you can totally i used to work with
this non-profit i'm gonna i think it's
called help me see but they had
essentially it wasn't automated but it
was generally automated like automated
assisting folks to do cataract surgery
because you had all these people who
were blind all over the world that just
needed a simple surgery uh to drain the
eye or whatever and they have like a
like a robot to train someone on it and
it's super easy and now you've got
literally hundreds of thousands of
people they're helping see all over the
world right just from the cost of one
machine
and like a little bit of training and
that's what i think this this should go
so that's good i didn't realize how jeez
i didn't realize how much we have a
massive shortage of a whole range of
doctors primarily because
the supply of doctors has been kept
artificially low by the medical lobby
right
so that applies primarily to primary
care physicians
uh
because
in like if you were
a medical student and you had a choice
to specialize for more money or
uh be a primary care physician you would
specialize as soon as possible yeah uh
so you you wind up with a shortage there
you went up with a shortage
on all sorts of fields
um but you you certainly have a shortage
of qualified surgeons in a lot of
areas of the country i worked in
healthcare software for four years
that's right in my 20s and i joked all
the time that healthcare is where good
ideas go to die it is where good ideas
go really oh yeah healthcare is some of
like the
um least efficient uh mismanaged stuff
in in
any industry it's 18 of american gdp now
by the way outcomes have not been
getting any better we're not getting any
kind of real bang for our buck all
that's happening is that the companies
in this industry are just getting uh
richer and richer and fatter and fatter
i have friends who are investment
managers who are begging for any reason
to short uh this industry because
they're like it's just profiteering and
gouging at the highest levels it's just
you know it's because our government's
just [ __ ] terrible at
getting things under control and so you
just have these companies that are just
like more you know maybe the worst uh
story i heard when i was running for
president a guy named dean caiman
[ __ ] yeah superstar genius inventor
invents portable dialysis it would
improve people's standard of living you
don't have to go to a dialysis center
and get strapped in if you're
diabetic um and so what happens
it gets lobbied as being bad for you
because they because right now these in
patient dialysis centers are such a
bonanza for in terms of money making
they make like billions of dollars a
year to cart people and strap them in
and so if you have a portable dialysis
machine you could like live a normal
life have it at home and then the
insurance companies who are making a ton
of money or like the dialysis company
like managed to be like no no portable
dialysis is terrible for you and so dean
cayman's like what the f
so so yeah it's like trying to try to
wade through that stuff like our system
is just so
screwed up in terms of like the purpose
is not to make you stronger and
healthier perhaps just to profiteer for
these companies so that is the con that
is the healthcare universe
now uh i'm with you and not being
concerned about the negative impact of
of these automations in large part
because there's a massive need but the
other thing is that the medical lobby
will just freaking get in there and and
they'll manage it and they'll they'll be
like
yeah they'll be there and be like okay
they'll be you know there needs to be a
surgeon chilling out and watching the
robot do its thing i mean like that
there'll be some set of things well over
time though you do see medical students
uh making different choices about how
they specialize
um so one discipline for example that
medical students are trying to avoid
radiology because they're like hey
looking at these films is not going to
be a winner yep because ai can 100 do
that yep you know what this does it
makes
the elizabeth holmes situation
so much more heart-wrenching if you will
because i i think quest diagnostics has
is a racket like i don't know and if you
want to get blood work done in new york
city your only option is essentially
quest diagnostics and it can be it's
thousands of dollars for certain
activities you have to go to them you're
on their timeline they don't give you
back they what they spit out is
ridiculous gibberish that you have to
have interpreted when they've done
millions of them they know whether
you're positive or not for x y z you're
testing for and so elizabeth holmes was
coming in and say hey we can
theoretically make this simpler which
she was fundamentally right on
her product was a load of crack like
that sort of thing and now anyone
no one wants to touch that industry with
a 20-foot pole right because
um of how terrible that went it would be
nice if someone could go in there and
build like a genuine theranos that
worked yes that's what made it so well i
was like this idea is theoretically
amazing even half of what she was able
to do if you couldn't do it on a prick
but if you could do it in an hour at
walgreens right um
even if the machine was
three times five times bigger and still
worked i don't know so
that would you know if you watch the
elizabeth holmes documentary i don't
know if you look very close i make a
cameo that's right you make a little uh
you're wearing a tie if i recall yeah
i'm in a white house photo with
elizabeth holmes
not only time wearing a tie the two
times were when i got invited to the
white house both times i wear a tie and
one time i showed up without a tie and
the staffer gave me his which i
appreciated thank you ronnie cho thank
you ronnie cho
for uh for giving me the tie off your
neck
did evelyn come both times or just one
just once just one you went solo the
other time yeah i wasn't i wasn't able
to bring someone oh you got plus one
yeah but both times it became cooler
yeah did obama remember you from
the first time okay i'm assuming i met
him people i met him three times uh and
then after i ran for president i had a
call with him so now i know what i am
but
so it was either the second or third
time
like he was going to shake my hand and
then someone whispered in his ear like
right as i got there and be like hey
this is andrew yang and he was a dude
and then he was like oh i know i
wouldn't recognize andrew yang so
like did he recognize it without the
dude simultaneously saying my name to
him i don't know yeah but now he knows
who i am clearly that's a hard because
come on i mean you know now he knows you
are yeah because now i'm like this yeah
yeah he knows he knew all the people
this you know yeah i wonder if you are
president for that you know when you're
out of office for a certain amount of
time you
would want to switch parties and you're
never able to you know
without push watching the republican
party being like i don't think i line up
with this and obama's like what are the
democrats doing i mean he came out
against wokeness he talked a lot about
people being outraged like social media
outrage part of the thing about wokeness
that um
is it's generational
yeah and and so if you're past a certain
age and you're like i don't know about
this is because you got
uh reared in a different activism
environment
no like i i'm 47 so i got reared
uh
in a different activism environment than
the the current uh
obsession with the power differential
right so yeah he's probably looking at
this i was wondering like you know and
you gotta think like clinton
for h.w bush you know like you're
watching like generations of politicians
been like i still have to be i'm still
the face of the party so i still have to
like i see some of these old politicians
show up and whatnot and then he's
treated like statesmen and they're yeah
yeah they do like royalty if or so
whatever it is yeah
to varying degrees yeah but yeah but but
it's like that's the thing you know i
mean it's fun
uh it's fun trying to avoid that destiny
yeah you and i have the same problem
we're too interested in
solving problems and doing things that
to be stuck in a lane like that would be
very very challenging
all right man any closing thoughts
well let us know what you want on uh
next week's american men segment
title tbd
[Laughter]
anyway love you guys see you next week
[Music]
you